du ahnst dass die korona diskussion
wieder hitziger wird wenn sogar
besondere intellektuelle wie der wendler
durchdrehen passiert gerade deutschland
streiten über steigende infektionszahlen
und mögliche party verbote das kann man
alles machen sicher gleichzeitig geht
aber eine andere wichtige frage fast
völlig unter warum wird hier manchen so
viel mehr geholfen als anderen
gerade wurde das kurzarbeitergeld bis
ende 2021 verlängert
da sage ich glückwunsch an alle
festangestellten ernsthaft für die 2,2
millionen solo selbstständigen läuft es
leider nicht ganz so doll
das betrifft ja unzählige jobs wie
fitness trainer innen
software-entwickler und natürlich die
ganzen künstlerischen berufen ja viele
von den rutschen in hartz iv denn die
einmalige soforthilfe von bis zu 9000
euro bekommt ja nur wer betriebskosten
hat miete oder so luxuriöse hobbys wie
weil sie nicht essen kaufen zählen dann
nicht dafür kriegen die künstler aber
warme worte von ganz oben
eines tages wurde es wieder kultur geben
bis dahin versuchen wir so gut wie es
geht sie zu unterstützen durch unsere
hilfsprogramme aber auch dadurch dass
wir sagen wie wichtig sie für uns sind
das bedeutet so viel kriegt meine frau
jedes jahr als einziges
weihnachtsgeschenk das gute gefühl dass
sie mir wichtig ist künstler und co sind
übrigens wirklich wichtig 2018 hat der
kultur und veranstaltungs sektor über
100 milliarden euro zur
volkswirtschaftlichen gesamtleistung bei
uns bei getrag mehr als die chemische
industrie
wer als selbständiger in hartz4 fällt
muss erstmal sein mühsam erspartes
größtenteils verbraten und vorher ein
bis zu 60 seiten dicken antrag ausfüllen
hier eine betroffene fragt den
wirtschaftsminister von
schleswig-holstein um rat
da wird es hier noch mal fragen ob sie
mir das nicht einmal vor rechnen können
weil ich freute mich schlau draus
geworden es gibt daneben auch
bedingungen die man im einzelnen daneben
auch sorgsam bis zu ende lesen muss und
da haben da an vielen stellen
festgestellt
das muss man lesen und verstehen aber
festgestellt meisten künstler können
leider nicht lesen wenn sie lesen
könnten hätten sie eine richtige arbeit
sollen die ganzen bratschisten doch um
schulen was anderes machen solo
selbstständige merken sie haben halt
keine lobby in diesem land in vielen
anderen europäischen ländern wird den
deutlich großzügiger und
unbürokratischer geholfen
in großbritannien zum beispiel gibt es
2800 im monat explizit auch für
privatausgaben frage warum macht man es
nicht wie beim kurzarbeitergeld einfach
60 prozent des durchschnittlichen
einkommens als staatliche hilfe
feierabend stattdessen kalender sprüche
die familien werden wieder feiern die
clubs und theater und fußball stadien
wieder voll sein und was für eine freude
wird das sein was für eine freude wird
das sei wenn die kanzlerin endlich
wieder durch die clubs zieht
vollgedröhnt auf der tanzfläche die
kleine party maus so andere werden hier
nicht mit sprüchen abgespeist freunde
sondern mit cash der tui-konzern zum
beispiel nur ein beispiel der tui
konzern hat gerade die zweite
finanzspritze gekriegt passend zum
herbstferienbeginn durch die warnungen
können urlauber gebuchte pauschalreisen
kostenlos stornieren und ihr geld
zurückbekommen oder umbuchen sowie
dieses ehepaar dass nun nach
schleswig-holstein fährt statt nach
teneriffa la ist doch fast dasselbe was
ist romantischer als einen
sonnenuntergang hinter dem penny-markt
von pinneberg wirklich liebe solo
selbstständige hättet ihr mal einen
touristikkonzern geerbt stadt weil sie
nicht blockflöte zu lernen noch mal 1,2
milliarden staatshilfe für die tui
insgesamt also drei milliarden
das erklärt auch den tui slogan so
entsteht ein lächeln ja tui hat so viel
steuer kohle kassiert der laden ist im
prinzip verstaatlicht wirklich gehen sie
einfach zum nächsten flughafen steigen
in irgendeinem tui flieger und zeigen
beim check-in der stewardess einfach nur
ihrem steuerbescheid der ganze bus
gehört in die müssen sie mitnehmen in
diesem sinne viel spaß auf den
seychellen ja mit den 32 milliarden
unterstützen wir als steuerzahler
übrigens auch die kreuzfahrtbranche also
eine industrie die
weltweit am boden liegt schon vor
gewinner gab es nämlich deutlich zu
viele kreuzfahrtschiffe klassischer fall
von blase trotzdem wurden noch mal 100
neue schiffe bestellt
das war im nachhinein betrachtet echt
blöd wie der chef der meyer werft
inzwischen an einer unserem einer kundin
hat gesagt ich brauche eigentlich eure
schiffe überhaupt nicht brauche ich gar
nicht den kam kannst du bei ebay
verschicken oder von mir aus vorne
eisberg fahren ist mir egal
ja es ist wirklich so bitter für die
branche was machen wir jetzt mit den
ganzen schiffen die hannover zum
beispiel steht inzwischen im heidepark
soltau als größte schiffschaukel der
welt auch die deutschen werften haben
vom start zuletzt nochmal fette
notkredite gekriegt nach dem alten motto
wir schaffen das die staatliche kfw bank
hat ausländischen reedereien unfassbare
25 milliarden euro geliehen damit die
davon bei deutschen werften schiffe
bestellt
klingt erstmal gut aber sollten diese
räder pleite gehen wofür gerade einige
spricht ist unser aller geld weg für
immer heißt übersetzt wir müssen jetzt
trotz corona in den herbstferien alle
kreuzfahrten machen sonst geht die
branche unter zusammen mit den 25
milliarden herzlich willkommen zu sonnen
mit dieser hoch
alle mann an bord wir stechen in see und
schwimmen den virus einfach davon
lassen sie uns gemeinsam träumen
stellen sie sich einmal vor die
hässlichsten plattenbauten aus
eisenhüttenstadt könnten schwimmen und
liebe zuschauer das können sie
kreuzfahrt urlaub wozu andere kulturen
kennenlernen wenn man auch mit 5000
anderen deutschen schneisen ins budget
fressen kann futtern sie schon zum
frühstück ihr eigengewicht in schrems
wir garantieren bei uns kommen sie aus
dem aufstoßen gar nicht mehr raus
die leber streikt die hose spannt heute
gehen wir nicht an land wer das nicht
was wir sie ja ziemlich erschießen sie
alter miesepeter schon klar die umwelt
noch die umwelt ja fast alle
kreuzfahrten fahren noch mit schweröl
sind also schwimmen den
müllverbrennungsanlagen aber ja aber wir
haben die filter und wir reinigen die
abgase alles und der schlamm wird
gesammelt und an land gebracht
und die bringen es irgendwo hin da ich
weiß nicht wohin es ja auch wurscht und
ganz moderne schiffe fahren mit
flüssigem erdgas was man zwar fast
nirgendwo tanken kann weshalb dann ein
eigenes tankschiff hinter dem
kreuzfahrtschiff herfahren muss aber
egal erdgas sauber co2 schon mal gehört
die schifffahrt produziert immer noch
deutlich mehr co2 als der autoverkehr
dafür hat die schifffahrt das bessere
entertainment oder gibt es in ihrem
renault twingo jeden abend ein
showprogramm mit stars wie
die herren oder der tochter von willi
herren a nein dafür wird in einem auto
aber auch kein asiatisches
servicepersonal ausgebeutet sie findet
jede verspannung so viele passagiere
sind an bord und die kleinen arbeiter
bringen allen freude freude das ist doch
etwas schönes kraft durch freude war
schon das motto bei den deutschen
kreuzfahrten in den 30ern liebe
zuschauer buchen sie jetzt egal was die
ganzen corona untergangspropheten vor
sich hin um das infektionsrisiko ist
viel geringer als sie denken das risiko
in diesen zeiten auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff mit vier bis sieben
1000 passagieren entspricht in etwa dem
risiko das man eigentlich wenn man eine
fleischfabrik heutzutage besucht ist und
damit sind wir auch schon bei unseren
nächsten tollen angebot zwei wochen all
inclusive bei tönnies im malerischen
rheda wiedenbrück alles was sich
schlachten meine damen und herren dürfen
sie selber essen
oliver ist dass milch zahl da bin ich
dabei tina hausten sonnenklar.tv
mit dieser höchsten tina hausten so
frage haben wir heute sozialdemokraten
im publikum
das ist nicht der fall ja es wird die
abwesenden genossen aber freuen dass
ihre partei es endlich mal wieder in die
schlagzeilen geschafft hat mit einem
weiteren bindestrich gesetz das mobile
arbeit gesetz von hubertus bindestrich
heilen jeder der möchte und bei dem die
arbeit das irgendwie zulässt soll ein
recht auf mindestens 24 tage home office
pro jahr haben frisch aus der
ideenschmiede der bienenfleißige spd die
gerade in umfragen unter die 15 prozent
gerutscht ist in wismar zumindest macht
sich sorgen
[Musik]
menschen im abseits dietmar wischmeyer
klagt an heute die spd
liebe mitmenschen ich habe ein ganz
schlechtes gewissen
wir haben uns in letzter zeit viel zu
wenig um unsere alte tante spd gekümmert
jedes neue so zum gesetz ein hilfeschrei
um aufmerksamkeit das gute kita gesetz
das starke familiengesetz das krass
geile gesetzte gesetz
und jetzt kommt auch noch der heil mit
seinen mindestens 24 tage home office
total gaga oder die 24 tage die es gehen
natürlich überhaupt nicht die gehen aus
meiner sicht an der realität vorbei und
die gehen auch an den wünschen der
menschen vorbei wer in politik muss ich
nach meinen wünschen richten ich wünsche
mir übrigens ein pony wann kommt das
hunderttausende haben wegen corona bald
das ganze jahr unfreiwillig home office
ohne lohnausgleich was diese wohl
wünschen recht auf home office sein
zusatz privileg für die eh schon
privilegierten im frühjahr waren 48
prozent der home officer beamte nur
sechs prozent arbeiter arbeiter kennt
sie noch spd einfach mal googeln
andererseits so ein fernfahrer kann doch
auch mal zu hause arbeiten oder der
gondoliere der schlachter
erde an spd firmen bei denen home office
funktioniert machen das von alleine weil
sie dadurch geld sparen
warum in ein gesetz gießen was der olle
markt ausnahmsweise mal von selber
regelt umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus
wie kann man denn den menschen das büro
nehmen da geht man doch hin um seine
familie nicht zu treffen oder um
spannendere leute kennenzulernen firmen
sind quasi das kinder des kleinen mannes
und wenn betriebs vorher nur noch als
zoom konferenz stattfinden sterben die
deutschen aus home office macht nichts
besser so und jetzt liebe damen schauen
sie mal an sich runter sitzt da noch
alles achtung home office macht
angeblich hängebusen ja oh mein gott ich
bin heute morgen zusammengezuckt oma in
gott
experten schätzen wer zu hause arbeitet
verbraucht 400 kalorien weniger am tag
da kriegen sogar männer hänge brüste
fazit das recht auf home office ist eine
klassische spd steiß geburt nach dem
motto was ist bekloppt überflüssig und
kostet den staat kein geld demnächst
frisch aus dem willy-brandt-haus das
gesetz über die teilnahme an der
schwerkraft und der rechtsanspruch auf
gehen mit zwei beinen
bis dahin bleiben sie aufrecht
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye